I got my blood lab done and the only thing that seemed off to me was the ALT, which was a nine
in a couple, which was a nine a couple months ago in a 23 last week. Other enzymes were
my normal, very low, is anything to be concerned about. Well, you know, I don't know. So when you're
looking at your lab results, what you see in the ranges is the lab ranges. So there's a difference
between lab ranges and functional ranges. So something could be within normal lab ranges,
but could be at the high or low end of that lab range would would usually make it out of
range as far as a functional range. But then you have to look at patterns. So when you look at a lab,
you look at a functional range, then you look at patterns of what's off, and then you look at
a previous lab. So you look at trends. So that's how you need to really read a lab report.
ALT of 23, I believe, still is within the functional range. If everything else was within the lab range,
again, it could be outside in the functional range. So we'd have to look at the big picture there.